lipid drafts are functional membrane
micro domain these regions are
characterized by highly ordered and
highly packed lipid molecules lipidraft
domains are slightly thicker than the
usual membrane
it is enriched in sphingolipids and
cholesterol lipidraft contains several
proteins including receptors lipidraft
proteins are like signaling proteins
such as gpcr can be their receptor
tyrosine kinase can be there there could
be resident proteins like GPI anchored
protein caviolin flotolene Etc also
there could be cytoskeletal protein like
adherine or integrines there are two
types of lipidraft type 1 which is
enriched with caviolin and it helps in
cavioli mediated endocytosis and the
type 2 lipidrafts are highly enriched in
neurons and they have fluotillin protein
in them
watch the full video to know more